we'll also be sending out an index
uh that identifies each section of house
bill 2
by division assignment so in
respect division 3 is pretty lucky
because out of the 291 sections only 28
are likely to be assigned to division
three and those are the 28 that i'll go
through today
so let me just pull up house bill 2 on
everybody see that yes
okay so the first section
that pertains to division three is
section 20
which begins at the bottom of page nine
and this is
one of several boilerplate sections that
have appeared in trailer bills for the
last
six to ten years this is a requirement
that the commissioner of hhs make
quarterly reports on the status of
estimated medicaid payments in relation
to actual costs
this language continues unchanged from
the previous biennium
the next section that pertains to
division three unfortunately they're all
in a block here
is 21 on the next page which allows the
department to fill
unfunded positions over the biennium
provided that the total expenditure for
those positions doesn't exceed the
amount appropriated so
this requires the department to stay
within its total appropriation for
personnel
costs but uh fill positions that are
unfunded as they arise
this language is unique to hhs other
departments don't typically have this
although i think corrections may have
had it
at times in the past
22 repeals a couple of programs that
repeals the congregate housing program
and the senior volunteer grant program
these are two programs that have been
suspended
many times over the last decade although
they were
funded in the current 2021 budget the
senior volunteer grant program was
funded at 750 000 a year in general
funds
and i'm sorry the congregate services
was funded at 750 000 per year in
general funds and the senior volunteer
grant program was funded at 100 000 per
year in general funds
so this section unlike sections in past
years doesn't suspend those programs it
section 24 is the cap on county payments
for long-term care services
this amount is changed each year in the
trailer bill
as you can see on line 22 here the
current fiscal year 21 cap
on county payments is 126.9 million
that would go up to 148.9 million in
fiscal 22 under the governor's proposed
budget
moving down to section 25 i wouldn't
necessarily call this boilerplate but it
is something that's
been in the trailer bill since 2012 i
believe
and this is the prospective repeal
regarding eligibility for
mental health services and this is one
of those items that if the committee has
any questions i would ask someone from
the department
to come over and explain that but we can
delay those until until the end of this
moving on to section 26 this delays the
repeal
of the department's exemptions from
certain transfer procedures
prevents agencies from transferring
between personnel class lines
but the department has an exemption to
that and they are allowed to transfer
between personnel class lines with
prior approval of the fiscal committee
that
section 27 is another that if you have
any questions i would ask the department
to
attempt to explain this is
this pertains to the use of met revenues
that go into the grand advantage health
care trust fund or the expanded medicaid
trust fund
my understanding is that this revenue is
needed to go into the trust fund in
order to
provide payments to critical access
hospitals but again that's something the
department can
sections 28 and 29 establish a new
emergency
services for children youth and families
fund
there is no funding in house bill 1 for
this
but the the fund is established here and
it's it would receive revenues from
gifts grants and donations so so i have
a question for you and this is more
about
um formatting i i i
noticed that it had this
hp2 has had the standard
use of bolding of new language
and and that's really great because it
helps you track
changes section 28 and 29
they say new sub paragraph a new section
but they don't have the bold and i'm
just curious
if there's uh what the what the rules
are
so of consistency so that i i know how
to really look at this and read it i
believe that's because they do create a
new subparagraph and a new section if
they were amending an existing
section and changing the language that
new sub-paragraphs new sections because
it
identifies them at the outset those are
not involved
i think it looks like representative
i just wondered i'm sorry
thank you thank you um
on the emergency services fund for
children youth and families
do we have a does it correspond to a
line in
um house bill one
i don't believe it does it creates a new
uh dedicated account but there's no
funding in house bill one
and it limits the revenue sources to
gifts grants and donations so there's no
so if they receive
some gifts grants or some
funding and they i get they deposit it
in the state treasury
and then they want to spend it what's
well i believe since this creates a new
dedicated fund dedicated account it
would be the same as the authority for
any other
dedicated account um what that is
specifically i'd have to look up
[Music]
hb2 so so some of my questions are
process oriented i'm reading
this paragraph establishing the
emergency services for children youth
and families fund
starting on line eight
and so there's a legislative language
that would be inserted into one of our
statutes
yes are we effectively the only
committee
that's reviewing this language to
determine its
uh its sufficiency uh or
or or are there any other policy
committees
involved in reviewing this particular
language
i suspect this language will only come
to finance
there have been times in the past when
uh
certain sections in house bill 2 have
been partitioned out and sent to other
agencies like ways and means for example
that may happen with a couple sections
elsewhere in the trailer bill
and the committee could do that with
this section
or others if it desired but my suspicion
is
finance will be the only committee in
this particular language
at the last game at the last chairman's
meeting
i sent off sections to all not all
policy committees there were a couple
that were involved but to most policy
committees
i sent off sections that i asked them to
review and get back to us if they wanted
any amendments
but whether or not they follow through i
don't know so for this particular
section uh representative weiler do you
think
do you think you might have sent it sent
it to children and family law
and d8 and excuse me hhsea
take a look at if i can find my list
um children i sent now i sent page 43
number 74. i don't know if i did not
send this one
um health and human services i sent
several pages but i don't think i sent
all this
i had page 21
on page nine and that's this one they
sent nine through 24
i sent to hhs as well as um
148 144 i sent those to
h i sent references to those hhs
so but i did not send this one to
children
i think children i sent only page 43
my general summary of my concern here is
i just
want to make sure that we're fulfilling
our responsibility
as a as a division to
ensure that we have an adequate hearing
on new
changes to statutes and that we're
getting
appropriate public input
because that's what a that's what a
policy committee would do if they had
so um okay so and and as a
in my previous two terms hb the hb2
processes were
pretty obscure to me i i didn't see
what was going on and um and
okay that's my comment thank you mr
ripple
are there any other questions here by
the committee
all right thank you you can continue
okay
section 30 and 31 online
18 and 22 relate to parental
reimbursement
of services provided to children in need
of services
this allows the department to motion the
court to terminate any such orders for
parental reimbursement
and again i would ask the department uh
for more detail on those sections
and this has gone back and forth at one
point if you had a child needed services
and they were there for
a year in the sununu center then
the parents might be untapped for
another 20 years for paying for that
hundred thousand dollars that it costs
for them to be in there a year
then we change the law subsequently to
say they only had to pay while the child
was in there and of course they looked
at their financial
need assess a financial assessment to
decide how much they would pay per month
and so many complained about the lengthy
period of time they were paying
back but we went to okay while the child
is there you've got to make payments
every month
but when the child leaves then you don't
so now we're back again until we can
continue to build unless
they come up with a decision to
terminate the requirement for that
particular
family yes
and moving on section 32
is boilerplate language that's been in
the last several trailer bills
it prevents the department from changing
eligibility standards or benefit levels
that would increase or decrease
enrollment without the prior
consultation of the house
hhs and elderly affairs committee and
section 33 starting at the bottom of
that page
states that any general funds
appropriated to hhhs
were supplanted by increased federal
funds uh would lapse
to the general fund so for example
say the department budgeted certain
medicaid services at 50 percent
and federal funds came in at 60
instead there was an enhanced federal
match
that difference uh under this provision
would last directly to the general fund
rather than staying within the
department
so i i have to i have to ask
who who has reviewed that policy to make
sure that that conforms with
cms or federal rules
i believe this language i believe this
language was included by the governor's
office i'm not sure that it's
necessarily an hhs
request so i i see
uh lisa english in the attendees list i
want
would i don't want to put her on the
spot but if you think
the governor's office did it maybe we
could just ask real quick if
uh the governor's office has reviewed
this and
it conforms to
federal rules and regulations sure
let me just find her on the list here
matt million is also here from the
governor's office
oh i didn't see him i just saw lisa
yeah sorry to put you on the spot if
you're not ready to talk to that
uh that i understand completely but if
you do know
and this was section 34 of house bill 2
um yes and not section 34 sorry let me
scroll up here it's 33
section 33 excess revenue from federal
match programs
yes i i would defer to the department
um on this particular
section um this did come from the
governor's office and i do think there
needs to be additional conversations
during the legislative phase
um and again i think the department
is probably the best to speak to exactly
uh what their
potential concerns might be and
ultimately whether this should move
so so fundamentally my my one question
is just
uh do do we do we know that this
active do we actively know that this
conforms with the federal rules and
regulations for their funding
um so so let's we can take that offline
unless
no i defer to matt on this one yeah mr
chairman if we could circle back with
you
and again probably loop the department
into these conversations as well to
understand
again the intent and also um just the
potential
uh pitfalls of of what this section
would
effectuate i'd appreciate a chance to to
bring
more voices to the table in that
conversation perfect
so i think we can go to section 34. we
can i'm just going to move them back
over into the
all right section 34 on page 12 states
that no state funds awarded by hhs
shall be used to provide abortion
services
section 35 on line 9 appropriates
that one's been in our loss for a while
right that's been in hb2 for a while
uh section 34 versions of this have been
in previous trailer bills
um it's also i believe been removed in
previous trailer bills
i can take a look at the history it
wouldn't surprise me if there
is an existing chapter law out there
that already contains language
similar to this okay but but
again i'm just learning to read format
since it does
it's not labeled as a a new section or
new paragraph and there's no bold in
there
that would uh suggest that this was uh
identical language in the previous hb2
um
no not necessarily it's it's simply
suggested it's a new section
it's not amending anything that already
exists
so uh kind of in a b priority could you
could you follow up and
let us know the history of that
paragraph please
okay
unless uh representative walner or
anyone wants to
jump in and say what they know and then
we could just
i can take a look i know sorry i'm sorry
i
yes i was gonna say kevin let's take a
look at the history of this
section 35 appropriates 10 million 43
to implement recommended recommendations
from the review conducted by alvarez and
marcel that was mentioned during the
department's presentation last week uh
the only thing i would note about this
section
and any other section in the trailer
build with an appropriation
is that these appropriations are in
addition to anything
in house bill one so this question came
up previously
as to where we would see these these
dollar amounts
in the operating budget and you won't
see them because
okay so now i have a mechanical question
for you
um as we're looking at
the the spreadsheets and the budget
briefing book to try to figure out
where we might uh reprogram monies
you know to and fro uh are
are we supposed to just have a post-it
note that we write to stick on the sheet
somewhere
uh or how how do we get a comprehensive
integrated view
of the monies in hb2 that aren't
currently in hb1
what i can put to i can put together a
list it's quite short there are only a
handful of house bill 2 appropriations
to hhs okay
here's the next few sections basically
that list looked like a spreadsheet then
that would work with
my brain so okay sure okay
kevin it would be helpful
when you're putting together that list
would is this
all general funds or can we use some
sort of federal matching funds for this
consultation this would be a general
fund appropriation
when 100 percent under the existing
under the existing section right when it
doesn't state the source of funds is
general funds by default
um that's not necessarily to say that
you couldn't
use other sources for this purpose
though
i do could you just repeat what you said
kevin this money is being
appropriated outside of the budget is
that what you said
it's an appropriation that's contained
in the trailer bill yep so it's outside
of the operating budget it's not in
house bill one
it's just in the trailer bill instead
and this is something that has been done
for
for many years okay
not capital budget nothing i'm saying
i'm
using the operating budget as synonymous
with house bill 1.
the capital budget doesn't show up on
hp1 does it
no this would be an operating approach
an operating budget appropriation it's
just not
one that's in-house bill one okay why do
i'm not sure this number might have been
settled on a bit later in the process
and so it was put into house bill 2. i
don't know the history behind it
okay thank you yep okay so said
a little differently just to make sure i
understand that kevin
yeah um if
we looked at the total spreadsheet of
the
governor's operating budget that we've
been working with
and we were satisfied that the revenues
and expenses were in balance
then this 10 million dollars
appropriated
in hb2 would throw us out of balance by
10 million
and we'd have to go find revenue to
cover it
well i'm not sure
what the governor's office has done with
respect to its
um surplus statement so they may have
been accounting for this appropriation
on the surplus statement
and it looks like matt has his hand
raised in the audience so
i'll bring him back over okay let's
see if uh representative rogers she's
she's got a cartoon hand up that's
pretty that's
you're on mute though representative
rogers
no i don't have anything up oh
i'm seeing what is that oh that's my
to a cartoon hand
that's funny sorry yeah sorry
um all right so matt you're not a
participant but you should be like yes
thank you kevin and hello again mr
chairman uh what i would direct to the
committee
to and the lba will be compiling
this separately as well but if you go to
the governor's executive budget
summary on page 16
you see the surplus statement for the
governor's recommended budget
of fy 22 and fy23
there is a line in there that is labeled
hb2
additional appropriations for 17.8
million
that is the sum of all appropriations
that are done
through hb2 as opposed to hb1
so yes we have accounted for those the
budget is still balanced with everything
that you see here in hb2
but as kevin said it's not tied to a
thank you for that representative earth
has a question it may be for you
it is for him i'm just curious why why
is it done this way
so representative i'd say there's a
number of reasons
and all of them for different
circumstances some of them
come to timing uh of when just the
budget deadlines occur
and ongoing conversations so that
certainly is one instance
another instance might be if uh the
department
would need flexibility between
accounting units
and that is uncertain during the
governor's phase
of course there would still be a process
for any transfers and these ultimately
would need to be inserted
into a specific area of any agency
so i guess what i would say is most of
these are attributable to timing
or just uncertainties that exist in
january and february
as opposed to may or june when the house
and senate go through and finalize the
budget
i'm sorry what was that representative
keep going
so is there any reason that we wouldn't
incorporate them into at least
the parts that belong at hs
you could certainly incorporate them
into a specific accounting unit
i think you know there's a long-standing
practice that some appropriations are
done through house bill 2
we've certainly seen that over the past
two bienniums and
bienniums before that as well
so to some extent it is the committee's
preference
in conjunction with working with the lba
to identify that the best home for these
appropriations but i don't know that it
makes a functional difference
thank you very much i don't see any
other questions we
can we can continue miss rival okay
section 36 continues the suspension of
catastrophic aid payments to hospitals
this is something that has been in the
trailer bill again since i believe the
section 37 is another general fund
appropriation of 1.5 million dollars to
provide grants to senior centers
or other organizations serving senior
citizens
and section 38 is another appropriation
two hundred thousand dollars to
[Music]
support
continued admission discharge and
transfer event notifications within the
behavioral health system and i would let
appropriation
section 39 relates to the 60 bed looks
like representative earth has a question
oh representative irf go ahead so do
those last two fall in that same
category of things
being appropriate in hb2 and not yes yes
they are and they're included in that i
have the governor's surplus statement up
now
and i see where matt referenced the 17.8
million
in house bill 2 appropriations in fiscal
22. so these would all be included
within that number
11 and a half almost 12 million dollars
at least from hhs
yes thank you
section 39 relates to the 60-bed
forensic psychiatric hospital
that was established and funded in the
that has not been built yet but this
would extend
the 17 and a quarter million dollar
appropriation
that was made in the trailer bill so
that would be non-lapsing
as currently written it would lapse at
the end of this biennium and this would
allow that to roll forward
admittedly there is a provision here in
rome 3 on line 10 for a potential
cap expenditure and i'm not sure how
that would be addressed in capital
budget
looks like representative walner has a
question oh okay sorry i was reading
representative and then if you have
follow-ups just have a conversation
so i was one you sort of just hit on it
kevin
i was wondering how does this interact
with the capital budget because
don't we have a um
top dollar amount that we usually look
for for bonding purposes um
so if we're bonding over here in health
and human services
and it's outside of the capital budget
shouldn't this
shouldn't this be in the capital budget
well i'll i'll leave that to uh
the the committees that determine that
i'm not sure how it would work just
based on reading this section because
the capital appropriation here is
contingent on other
things happening it's contingent upon
federal funds
not being available for example so
mechanically i'm not sure how it would
work
and i do you have any um do you have any
idea what federal funds they might be
considering do we have any and when
those would be available
i'm not sure i think the department
might have to answer that question at
some point
okay okay
thank you so this was this is the
appropriation from
we had this in the previous budget it
was and i just wanted
it is and i just want to clarify what i
said i don't believe the appropriation
was 17 and a quarter million i think the
general fund appropriation was somehow
less than that uh but whatever that
amount 16
i remember 16. okay um section
one on line three allows that to roll
forward for the next fiscal year
for the next biennium okay
okay thank you i think this is something
we should really talk to the department
about mechanics is how this is going to
work
and move on to i want to stick a second
on the
on the uh psychiatric hospital okay um
in in the military there were hard and
fast rules
where you just could not use
operating money for capital expenses and
vice versa
there were bright legal lines
do we have something like that in new
hampshire
or or is there is there there seems to
be some discretion
about when operating money can be
capital money
well you can certainly fund capital
projects through the operating budget
there's no restriction on that
may be norms regarding
what capital funds can be used on
operating projects for
all right so you just taught me
something new hampshire doesn't have a
legal
barrier between operating and capital
funds
no
let's see moving on to i think i lost my
place here sorry
page 13.
okay thank you uh section 41 moves the
control drug prescription health and
safety program from the office of
professional licensure and certification
and after that we'll move on down to
section 106.
now on this one section 41 i
i think hhs has revealed
re um reviewed bills in the past
about
i think we lost you there
representatives
um maybe i'm just not close enough to
the mic but
but hhs i think have reviewed
bills in the past on the controlled drug
prescription health and safety program
and so i'm just wondering um
if uh this is this should already be in
statute or if something
got the itl by hhs
well the program itself is already in
statute i believe the language is
transferred over in its entirety but
it's moved from dlc
to hhs
can you repeat where it's moved from uh
from the office of professional
so that division one would have a hand
in as well since that's where it
so um chairman
i don't know a lot of i mean i don't
know a lot about this but
um have we had
any contact with um the office of
professional licensure
and with health and human services about
this transfer have they
contacted anyone is this something they
well well we have uh four-handed
audience so i think people wanna people
wanna talk
okay who who are they
we have matt john williams
uh patricia tilly within hhs
looks like three hands let's go in the
order you just
thank you mr chairman uh my comment was
actually related to
uh one of the last things that
representative earth had said
specific to why appropriations might
live in hb2
as opposed to hp1 a number of these
items are also designed as
one-time appropriations which is another
reason why they might appear
here as opposed to the operating budget
given that they're not anticipated to
occur either in both years of the
biennium or
on an ongoing basis
did you have anything to add on the
controlled
nothing other than that we've worked
with oplc and hhs
to incorporate this transition into hv2
representative walner do you have a
question for the governor's office
no i i would like to i just wondered
about
the uh conversation had had the
conversation happen between the two
agencies
right so we're going to go to mr
williams next in hot pursuit of your
question
okay thank you mr chair and members of
finance division three
uh this is john williams i'm the
director of legislative affairs and
with your permission uh mr sheriff i
could have deputy director
uh patricia tilley also join me because
i have a feeling if there's some
additional questions she will certainly
provide additional clarity and support
to the questions
very good and as we're bringing this
uh miss tilly into the conversation uh
in addressing
represent walnut's question regarding
the engagement between the agency
we have been working collaboratively
with the office of professional
licensure for
a couple of years now relative to at a
minimum gaining access to the
information and more recently in the
last six months
on a conversation around where the
program should be appropriately housed
particularly
given its connection to public health
and the benefits to
uh the population that usurp we serve
around it being housed within our agency
so the
current uh executive director attorney
lindsey courtney has been wonderful to
work with they are fully on board
with the um having the your alpha
mark just died i'm sorry uh and so
attorney
lindsay courtney the executive director
is is supportive of having
this house with the department not only
because of how it aligns with public
health needs
uh and and being better housed with our
agency but also as she's doing an
incredible job
uh relative to identifying structures
and organization
at the office of professional licensure
around their
board functions their licensing function
and their regulatory functions
that the prescription drug monitoring
program as it currently sits with them
doesn't align as well as it would within
our agency around public health
i would also uh just ask a deputy
director tilly if she could
offer some additional insight around
that
but i can say personally we've been
working directly
uh with oplc on this and they and they
are supportive of this
so representative does that satisfy your
question
uh rep uh we still have ms tilly that
can
speak to it yeah yes thank you i would
like to hear
um from um miss tilly about
about the transfer and
what sort of input have we had from the
health and human service committee about
this
all right miss tilly take it away can
you address that
yes thank you so much and again this is
patricia tilly from the division of
public health services thank you for
inviting me into this conversation so
john did a great job of just sort of
wrapping up that we have had a
several year process right now of
conversations with oplc
and also having policy conversations um
around the use of the pdmp
data and how we can best protect it
secure it
and use it to inform our public health
policy
and our behavioral health policy so um
i think there's a a couple of of
questions on the books one
um we have um we have thoroughly vetted
this through oplc
with the two departments are in
agreement that it seems to be a good fit
for it to sit here especially with some
of our other business lines of work
around handling other sensitive data and
registry type data um and then
uh forgive me i've i've lost the last
half
of a representative wellness question
no i think i think that answered it i do
have one further question though that i
would like to ask
so the budget that
um the oplc had
for this activity will be transferred
over to the department of health and
human services
correct that's my understanding and much
of that is um they have some federal
funds
um in addition to other funds to run the
program
and where would we see that in the where
will we see where will we see that
transfer
of um income and
expenditures in the budget has it
is it in the budget that we have in
house bill one
and uh represent walder mr chair i would
defer
to either the governor's office to to
matt and or to karen rounds they
probably would be better able to
identify
where in the offering but operating
budget that that transfer would take
place
obviously from a different division into
division three
uh budget so i i would defer that
question to
one of the financial folks if ms rounds
is on
uh it'd be great to bring her in because
i'd also just like a detailed question
about whether
we're starting up a new account line for
this
that we'll see in the future in hb one
good morning chair good morning did you
hear my question while you were being
transferred
i did uh yes the the appropriations
are within the public health department
our division rather
um and they have been transferred as
they would have been budgeted at oplc so
there are no increases
um it is just transferring those
accounting units over
to the division of public health so is
this in the spreadsheet now
or or or will is that just something we
have to factor in
no it's already in hb1 uh reflected
um it's already there okay
fantastic isn't it is it
is it merged with any other funds or is
its
own distinct line they're their own uh
accounting unit and it's probably more
than one accounting unit
um and those will be covered when we
cover the division of public health i
believe that's the last division we
cover
a week and a half from now or so very
good representative
weiler has had his hand up a while yes
sir
all right thank you i just want to point
out that this goes on for eight more
pages
in this item if anybody's interested in
the detail and
we should keep track of things where
money is transferred into hhs
when we compare the spend from previous
biennium that we ought to
be aware of the fact that this is new
money that came in
from with other parts of the budget and
not
if we try to make a uh a total
comparison
thank you i'm not seeing any other
questions uh miss tilly
uh did you have anything you wanted to
say that we've not asked you
um thank you representative edwards um
as
uh karen rounds described when we do our
dphs review
um we'll surely have an opportunity to
let's see so we're moving on down
moving on now to section 106 which i
just need to find here
okay section 106 here
relates to the veterans home and it
basically gives the veterans home the
same language
that hhs has elsewhere in the bill
allowing them to fill their unfunded
positions during the biennium
provided that their total expenditures
for personnel services
don't go up or don't exceed the amount
appropriated and this
i need to go back and check they may
have this language currently and they
may have had it previously
something that the veterans home has had
in the past
likewise section 107
provides the veterans home with special
transfer authority
and this is something that exists in the
let's summarize that if you could
summarize the special transfer authority
how how would you say it in a few words
uh well it gives the commandant broad
authority as you can see here on lines
26 and 27
they're author they're authorized to
create accounting units expenditure
classes
as necessary to address present or
projected budget deficits so that's
that's quite that's unusually broad but
it is authority that they've had
thank years but they still need to go
to gnc
for approval of those transfers what is
the gnc
section 108 also pertains to the
veterans home
this i believe is new
actually they may have had this before
as well uh relates to per diem payments
and states that actually i need to take
a closer look at this one to see if this
is
to see if this is something they've had
previously
yeah i'm having a hard time reading it
just because i
i want to associate the term per diem
with the payment
to um like a
a day-to-day nurse a visiting nurse
the rest of it doesn't read that way to
i may have to take a closer look at
these veterans home sections to see what
they do and also see if they've had
these sections previously
okay when when are we scheduled to see
the veterans home they're
coming right they are last or second to
last i think you may be seeing them on
the same day as public health in about a
week and a half
and they can talk about those sections
as well as sections 109
and 110 which also exempt them from
statutory provisions related to
transfers
so that section 110 actually is the last
section under the purview of division
three so
that's all i have for now unless the
committee has any questions
all right so i'm looking to see if
anyone's got their hand up in the
committee
and i'm i'm not i'm not seeing any
um and so let's let's give it about 30
seconds
to see if anyone in the attendees list
wants to raise their hand uh if anyone
in the attendee list wants to raise your
hand
go ahead i would just ask you if you
have comments to speak uh very directly
to
a particular section that we're
reviewing and that you keep your
comments to the policy
i'm not seeing any attendees hands are
you
i'm not so i think
we've successfully done a walkthrough of
hb2
and there's a few outstanding issues
were you able to talk and record the
open items mr ripple i mean that's a lot
to do both i think joan has been keeping
track of the committee's questions so we
should be all set
okay so before we come off of this let's
do something we've not done before
uh mr feldstein would you would you
summarize
what you have down as open items
sorry yeah of course representative i
have
um let me just pull this up here i have
a request from representative edwards
for the governor's office
and the department to provide
information on section 33 of hb2
regarding the need for the provision
i have a separate request from
representative
walner regarding for the department
regarding what federal funds will be
used for their forensic psychiatric
hospital
and provide additional information on
mechanics with the budgeting
and then um a few requests for us of the
lba
regarding section 34 of hbb2
and looking at the history of that from
representative wallner
and then for representative edwards to
create a spreadsheet with funded
provisions from hp2 not included in hp1
anyone from the committee think that
something got missed that that sounded
i think representative nordgren that was
a thumbs up you're okay or you have a
comment
i think she's okay all right well so
that
concludes this portion of the of today's
work session um we're gonna meet at one
o'clock
but i i would like to spend the next 30
minutes or so with the committee
talking about this work session
and well using this work session to talk
about future work
sessions this is probably not going to
be of much interest to the public
because it's really just i think
the division iii needs to talk about
some ways of working because
i i don't really have a firm grasp
on what a finance work session looks
like i have some assumptions
about what it could look like but but i
think it's important for us to get in
sync
on on how we're going to use these work
sessions in the future
so um so representative
wallner looked like you were ready to
talk did you or was that just
no okay so um
you can you can drop miss tilly if you
want uh
uh mr ripple and uh and and
ms rounds is always uh she's sort of our
extended team
member here um but so what i think
of when i think of the term work session
i put it in the context of my experience
in the other
policy committees where we would have
um executive sessions on bills so we
would you know have the type of meeting
or hearing
where we get public input and all of the
uh reps would ask questions of the
people coming in to testify
but there really wasn't crosstalk or
debate
i i and then they would take a look at
that bill
in an executive session and determine
you know uh the pros and cons and and
then vote
you know otp or itl or some other motion
um
at the end of it now i don't see us
doing a lot of voting but i do see us
needing to have uh interactive
conversations with each other
that are open to the public so they you
know the public is aware of what we're
thinking and
and why um and and so
so so my overall concept and i'm asking
you to clarify this so that i know what
we're doing
uh is to is does that sound like a
standard
work session in division three and
um i i didn't see which hand went up
first
uh thank you mr chair what we've got to
do is find out
how much of the revenue is
is going to go to the hhs and that's
complicated by the fact that uh
we just saw a transfer from oplc
into hhs which
shouldn't be counted as as new revenue i
don't think
then one of the things we've done in the
past especially in the senate
where they were expecting a grant
and it would come through fiscal they
took it out of the budget completely
to make it look like it was less and we
are also aware
in many of these programs that
money is coming from federal federal
grants but
we don't know exactly how much but many
many of these grants are like three-year
grants and if this is the first year of
the grant coming into this budget then
we can assume that the other ensuing
years will be about the same amount
uh that isn't always done sometimes they
don't put a figure in because they say
well we're not
sure but it's within a small percentage
depending on what other states are doing
with those grants so
it's it's not much variation from
what they're getting for the first year
of the grant
so we we need to take account of all
those things then we need to make some
tough decisions of
where we save and go back through and
see
uh each person will want to identify
targets some of us
are going to get a lot of feedback from
counties on reducing
the county caps it's a huge increase for
counties
to struggle with it from three percent
the typical three percent to 18 percent
increase
so we want to look at those things we
want to make some decisions we want to
have to
have to have kevin keep as well as
prized as
how much how much we can spend versus
how much they want to spend those are
going to be tough decisions so
that's that's going to take most of our
walter did you did you want to help me
understand the concept
of how we use worksafe well
i i would say that you know i've been
here i've been on finance a long time so
i've
work sessions have been done in a
variety of ways
it seems to me that one thing that you
need we need to do
is and people have done it in different
ways but
is to get focused on
the areas that um we either have more
questions about
or people feel that there needs to be
appropriations need to be different than
what what the governor has proposed
but we need to start sort of whittling
it down
we've actually done it in ways where
we've gone through
kevin probably remembers doing this a
few times
go through every page and if the page
looks good
if we you know as a division we
think the page looks good or the
program looks good with the funding it's
got we'd put a check mark by it
we could always go back and revisit but
um it would get us so that we could
focus in
on the areas that we had the most
questions
or we needed to take a look at the
appropriations
or the staffing or whatever it was in
that in that area
but unless we do that unless we we need
to find a way i think
to get focused on certain areas of the
budget i mean some lines are
some areas are really big and we haven't
gotten even to the big ones yet
when we get to the medicaid lines we're
really into very large
so let me let me um drill down in your
comment there i think it was
very useful and i have a segue to to say
how i think we might do that focused
effort mr
ripple could you uh pull up and share
the excel sheet that you sent this
morning
that shows fy 18 and 19 and
i'm not going to ask you to justify it
i'm just going to have people look at it
make sure they got it and
i'll talk to what i'm doing with it sure
representative norgren you took your
hand down i assume this because
representative said what you wanted to
say
okay so this is as good a place to end
up as any
but but um okay so
so what i have been asking mr ripple to
do
and what he's delivered to us is
is this a is a very similar view
of the governor's budget um as we have
in our
in our budget book this is like pages
three
four and five um in soft copy
and extended so that we see what actual
fy 18 and 19 were as well
and i i've been asking for this because
i i being new to the committee i
particularly need to see a longer
historical tale
so that i can tell what how we're
trending
and so um so what i'm i'm going to be
doing with this
could you scroll down to the bottom of
child development program the dehs just
it's just it's almost right there right
there okay
so so what i've been doing uh
as of this morning is going through
and looking at the year-to-year
percentage growth
in each of these line items um
and uh and particularly where
the the the amount of money
is considerable taking a special look at
that
like for example if i had done dehs
in the client services field operations
it would it would show that we went from
11 million and 18
to projected 13 5 and 23
and and there'd be a year to year growth
there
now that would just be data
that would indicate whether or not this
is an area we want to drill down
but i'm i'm a very top-down
structured thinker you know it's how you
design software it's how you do a lot of
things
but that's how i think and so i
i am proposing that we use this sheet
so that when we get together in work
sessions
we can highlight at the higher level
the the areas of concern that we have
and and this can trigger us to go deeper
into the budget books
for information and to ask questions so
that that's
that's basically how how i see us
doing kind of a top-down structured uh
review and uh assessment of the
governor's budget
well i think the history is is
for this sheet is good to have the
history i do think though you need
to be going back at some point
and looking at the at the pages and at
the programs
because even i mean even these
lines are comprised of a lot of
different
a lot of different things so if you want
to be specific about
a line that you think is over budgeted
you can't just you can't just reduce the
bottom line you can't just
reduce the total you need you may need
to
be specific about how you want that
reduction to happen
oh oh sure i'm just going to do a flat
back of the budget reduction no no no no
no no no
i'm just i'm just trying to describe a
top-down way to
maintain focus i i would not at this
level
start recommending cuts like for example
what i might do
is on line uh excel line 27
uh briefing book line 47
where it says aptd grants
kind of just i would would look at the
trend and look at the numbers and i'd go
okay that one's probably okay that's not
one that i really need to drill down
into immediately i that would be
something i'd look at later but but then
uh as contrasted with the client
services field operations line
that that that looks like it's going up
five to eight percent per year
which is higher than the rate of
inflation i'd probably and it's a
significant amount of money it's 13.5
million by the time it's the budget's
done
that would probably jump out at me as
one
area that i'd want to drill down deeper
to understand it
even at this level i wouldn't say let's
cut that because you've got to dig
into it to figure out what's in there
why it's
trending that way but this is sort of to
me
almost like a radar system to where you
can see the the major pings
in the budget for where we need to focus
um no i just think that we're going to
need to go back
and to the pages and look at more
specific information
um i mean for instance if you take
oh i'm trying to look at an item that
that does
increase okay so the client services i
mean there's a lot of things we need to
find
out about that before i mean we might
put it on our radar but we
there's a lot of things for all we know
they became responsible for a lot of
other things in the department that they
hadn't done before um
so we really have to drill down into
those numbers
i i think we're in violent agreement but
because you've been doing this for
24 years and i've been doing it for 24
days
it's sort of like you have a phd in this
and i'm
in the freshman the freshman
introductory course
i i'm explaining how i'm viewing our
process
and hoping that it it fits
with with where you're at and and so
uh represent representative uh nordgren
did you
you had your hand up your you keep
coming in and out
well mary jane is covering a lot um
yeah i think what we need to do is
finish
all the work with every department
and then go back to these and then
pick out where we want to go to the
budget book
so i think that's really the process
for the next i think we need to set a
timeline
with our calendar so we know exactly
where we are when we get to
the point of finally making the cuts
and and going to those pages
in the budget book okay that's a good
comment let me let me say a couple of
things about that
one let me verify that you've received
the calendar of for march from mr ripple
showing sort of each day of the
month of march the things that we're
going to do that day
as a committee because that's a nice
overview
so is that the one that we got weeks ago
well and then he updated it when we
moved uh things around this week
so so the most recent update was like
towards the end of last week i think
this one could you send that out again
just to make sure we all have that or
yeah i don't remember getting it yeah no
i'm i
i like it so much i cut the relevant
portion out and i've taped it to my desk
so it's it's sort of like my day planner
um and i
and and i i absolutely agree with you as
well
that that uh we have to be getting into
the detail in the budget book before we
can
intelligently think we should in add
money or cut money
you recommended that we continue as we
have been that
because that was the other question i
wanted to ask now that we're sort of
halfway through
do we like
the way we're going through the budget
with the the department presentations
followed by uh the excel sheet in the
in in between the budget book items
is that is that do we still like that
consistent approach and should we
continue that with the remaining
departments
representative yeah just a comment um i
i wish we were using the briefing book
more
um i think when the department sends us
a huge package to look for the neck
to look at the next day it'd be much
better if we could send those out
sooner and we could use them along with
the briefing book to get ready
for that uh presentation but
um one of the things mary jane and i
talked about
as in the future it'd be good if the
briefing book we got
in the first place contained all those
presentations
so we could have everything in one place
and not get you know one the night
before
i i think that's good feedback and and i
i suspect
uh the department would have a reason
for
telling us why we're getting things in
the sequence we're getting them in the
timing but
but i don't want to assume any of that
mr ripple do you want to speak to that
or ms rounds
i know i know that you're sending us
as far as why the calendar was set up
the way it was it was simply a matter of
uh
the schedules that worked for people and
and how much time we thought needed to
be allocated to each area
there wasn't necessarily any rationale
for the sequence other than that
okay but representative nordgren is
suggesting that
she would like to have the presentations
earlier
and during the briefing time that we
have
oh i see i think she's asking
that more emphasis be put on the
briefing book pages
because uh that that's material to the
way she looks at
uh the budget process okay i
i think that's something that uh that
with with regards to the presentations
if you don't
mind chair i can speak to that um
it's truly a time constraint issue there
there's a lot of competing demands on
the directors
and and so preparing those several weeks
ahead of time it is
very difficult from a time constraint
issue so that's
i i assume your priority is that budget
book that that
and and so you put all your effort into
that and then
after the fact people work on their
presentations using historical documents
and modifying it a bit
yes yes we the priority definitely is
the budget briefing book that takes
several months to put together we
started that back in
november december so that is the
priority to have those done
and of course as you all know the
directors have
other competing priorities beyond the
budget too
they actually have work to do and they
do yeah
so and double work with covet
unfortunately
okay so so so i think the
the short answer representing nordgern
is is
i think we're going to try with the
departments to have us spend more time
looking at the budget books when the
departments brief us
and we'll see how it goes because put a
lot of time in these presentations and
and i would say that most of the
presentations do incorporate everything
that we say in the briefing book
the briefing book is really meant to be
a resource
that as you start to review and try to
make decisions on
on reductions or increases that you're
able to go to that
accounting unit in the briefing book and
be reminded exactly what it is
um just in case some there's not
somebody from the department available
or you're working on it
you know off time um that
that you have those resources available
but um we can certainly
you know talk about them in the
presentations to the extent that people
thank you um so so mr ripple
uh i'm looking at the
the march calendar you put together for
us
and uh what i'm not maybe it's on here
but
but could you tell me our drop dead date
where division three should expect to
have its work
kind of done to for the overall finance
committee to
absorb our work yes
the divisions let me just pull up this
the divisions need to have their
recommendations in by i believe the 26th
so i currently have the 24th as the
final
day of work sessions but you could go
okay so i'm just looking at the words
in the calendar you sent the words say
budget slash
bill work sessions yep but this one
is an important one because this is this
is what you
think it should be our planning drop
dead date
even though the 26th is our real drop
it would be ideal if the committee could
get all its work done by the 24th but
that doesn't
always happen so yeah i so yes the short
answer is i had planned on the 24th but
you do have an extra couple days
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna write a note
on on my desktop that says we're going
to try to
plan drop dead on the 24th
yep
so those are those are important dates
for us
all to have in mind and uh
i'll i'll try to work out some thoughts
on where we can be with the work
sessions that are already
anticipated in here so uh representative
yes uh i want to remind you that he puts
the 24th
all our lba people are putting in
18-hour days and more
no weekends during this budget time
period so
you know he's got to get everything
perfect he's got to have other people
cross-check his work he's going to spend
some very long days
making sure he has everything perfect as
well as all the other
lba in the other division so
try to be sensitive and make sure we get
it ready so he doesn't have to work 20
hour days
and getting ready for the presentations
to the full house and the
so so i think that's a great comment and
and let me come back to you mr ripple
and say i'm i'm assuming
you've built in some time to sleep if we
get our work done on the 24th
i have i have and we will have time to
do uh data entry into the budget system
and
all that over the weekend so there's
time built in for that
so so if you need this to be the 23rd
instead of the 24th you'll speak up
i will but the 24th should be fine
so representative nordgren you have your
hand up
yeah i was just looking at the calendar
here on my phone
and it looks like next week we would
only meet
two days i'm questioning
whether the house will be
having meetings maybe on town meeting
day
that's not in our calendar but i'm not
sure
we can't do virtual that day i also
um am unsure about the
three different house sessions on the
11th
that's not what i've heard this house is
doing but
i don't have any communication with the
speaker so
um i just would maybe check on that
because i'm worried we're really going
to end up with some long days at the end
if we um don't do fridays
and we and we think we're having house
sessions
thank you okay so let me take that
last part first uh the house sessions
uh what i knew was what
is today tuesday what day are we it is
wednesday
wednesday's wednesday yeah okay so
welcome to our world so uh monday
or tuesday the speaker was going to be
working with
um the sports center to coordinate
schedules
and so i'm expecting any day now
any hour now for there to be a plan for
when we're going to go back into house
session
i think i think what mr ripple probably
did with these thursdays
is just put the house session question
mark
for us to just know that maybe we want
to stay away from
scheduling those days because um
we may end up having the house session
scheduled that day
i i don't i don't think we're going to
have more than one or
two days at most in march if
for a house session that's that's what
i'm hearing uh
representative weiler do you want to
comment further on potential house
session days
well i'm also thinking of full committee
session days there's been some bills
passed on to us
most of them ended up in division one
when they get to them they're going to
have to come back before the committee
and have a vote have them forwarded
onto um the house
for a house session so even though we
haven't as far as i know gotten any of
the bills that were
passed this last session some of them
did go on in division one which will
require us to have a full session day at
some point
maybe we can do it in a half a day we'll
see
thanks do you want to tentatively
uh put your finger on one of the days in
march where we may have a full finance
committee day
or is that i don't want to put you on
the spot either well
i'll have to get together with lynn over
and see how she's coming on
fitting those bills into her schedule
and when she thinks she'll be done
very good and then representative
nordgren i recalled that she said two
things that i wanted to follow up on and
i did this
the other question is um the town
meeting day next tuesday
i'm unsure if the house will still be
here
meeting day is so i need an education
what is a town meeting day
voting oh i get it or towns or towns
but i don't know if that's the day we
need to take off if there are people
who are going to be involved in that or
if the house
has a full body is taking it off just
because of this virtual
i don't know i
i plan on anticipating i see i have
three towns so i'm going to try to get
to at least one of them
okay okay well you'll have to go
vote but it's not like any of us are
selectmen or
or registers of pro justices of the
checklist or anything that would require
us to spend the whole day there
quite often we have that happen but i
don't think any of the people
speak up if anybody is involved in a
town where they got to be there
at the polls all day so that's just how
i figure out what's going on in my town
and and well people grab me and talk to
me so
we're penciled in for uh nine o'clock on
the ninth
oh wait a minute that's another division
all right so we're not penciled into
meat
on we are not on the ninth no
do you wanna do you wanna pencil
something in in the afternoon
either morning or afternoon i don't
think we have to have we don't have to
have the whole day off but
so um i did not make sense to look at
the fridays before we look at that
particular
day
i don't i don't know it just seems like
people are working on the weekends and
giving them some time to work on friday
would be
kind of good but um would you rather do
so mary jane do you know when the gopher
i'm sorry uh represent weiler i have not
heard
what time it is i figured that they know
they have both you and i to
to schedule a round i hope i hope so
so at least they maybe let us know a
little bit further in advance
yeah the other thing that you guys are
involved in is that joint fiscal
committee i think and
and and i'm not sure when the next one
is but those tend to be friday mornings
right
so so mr ripple if you could just add
that as a as a note
since it's putting demands on our
committee i have a thing on the 12th i
just realized as well
having spoken out okay
all right no beer for you fair enough
okay so so
so let's let's let's
jess sharon has a question
oh there it is yes go ahead
representative norton
no sorry i didn't hit my hand
sorry i opened a can of worms no it no
it's all good conversation i think i
think
we're we're smarter as a committee as a
result so
i think what we've done is we've added a
work session
on tuesday afternoon the 9th
and then what is our last hearing our
last
hearing from the department is scheduled
for the 15th is that correct
okay now now so
that already includes a continuation of
public health
so so that's so we're probably good
right
you do you do you have any reason to for
concern that we don't have enough
department days scheduled
i think you have enough department day
scheduled and
five work sessions and the possibility
of opening up
and opening up the afternoon of the
ninth and possibly
thursdays and as well and which there
are no house sessions i think you have
enough time to do your work
okay so just keep in mind everyone on
the committee
uh i i i'm trainable i
i don't know exactly what i'm doing but
i'm trainable talk to me
uh if you guys something mj i see
i see her but i was in a sentence so
representative walner on the ninth what
time do you think you'll
come in to work and how long do you
think you'll work i
because it looked like we were empty
that day that day i
scheduled something for that afternoon
so i'll tell you what what what's your
preference
i i think if we got together for a
couple hours
given that we still have division uh
that we need to hear
just i i just want to make sure that our
our
our ways of working together are coming
together and maybe two hours of
of talking and working with each other
will be useful just to learn
so so what what's your pleasure could we
come in
can we come in at noon and be done by
like three
two thirty to three i'm okay with that
do you have an issue with starting at
noon mr ripple
nope not at all i don't know what your
union contract says whether
i need to send you a sandwich if we do
that no
union okay all right so so we'll go
from noon to three and honestly i don't
i don't think we'll need
uh i
would like to tell you a little bit
about
a conversation i had uh
with with some folks about the revenue
estimates
as you know um we've been talking
about uh an 80 million dollar shortfall
overall in the biennium between
the house ways and means revenue
estimates
and what the governor's budget
anticipates
and as a result of there being about it
i guess it's more precisely 77 million
but
but in any case ways and means is
projecting
revenues and we're seeing a shortfall
between that and the governor's budget
we're getting feedback that
the governor office is very confident
in their revenue estimates more
confident
than they are in the ways and means
estimates
and and so um
so while we will be looking for
ways to tighten the belt if we
the governor's budget or governor's
people
won't be participating with us to a
great extent
so so we're going to have to do some
path
finding on our own looking at
potential reductions
so that we're ready if the worst case
starts to appear
um but um but so i wanted
i wanted to open that up and let you
know that that's where we're at
representative weiler i have a lot of
faith in in the methods that
ways and means committee has used for
the past two or three budgets
and they have been very close and
we have of course put the budgets with
their revenues
and i don't think we've regretted it
whereas if we went with the governors i
think we would find ourselves short so
i think that you know within our own
family if you will
they're part of the legislature they're
the ones that are responsible they've
given us
and that's that's the pattern we go with
ways and means comes and tells us this
is what we think you'll have
they may come back and later in march
and say okay we can add another 10
000. but and then the senate goes to the
senate
and march and april is sits key months
and the senate gets to look at them so
the senate may come back and say
okay we've got another 20 or 40 or 50
million
and if that's the instance then we ought
to be able to say when we put things
aside
the priority is on this one that we just
cut that's
that's the highest priority to put back
the money in there this is the third and
this is the fourth priority and whatever
but so we can go to them and negotiate
and say you know
okay you had more money than we did but
we think you put it in the wrong place
we want to wish to say that rather than
put it there you should have put more
here and more
here and so on so that that's one we
keep in mind when we do
are forced to make cuts is prioritize
where we'd restore
that's the way the game is and that's
the way it's been going on for years and
i think kerry jane can agree and
then sharon norgren would say that's the
experience
thank you uh representative norgren
yes um i would just want to stress
that the ways and means committee and
just you can talk about this
will come to another discussion
about revenues um in a few weeks so
before we finish and i don't know
if you either you or representative
weiler know the time frame
um which might be helpful so
so go ahead representative weiler i
think you had an answer
i don't i don't know yet when we'll hear
from that
adjustment by ways and means they would
probably want it as late in the month as
possible so they could
get they get to look at the most
parameters but
yes they will give us an adjustment for
along the line
and if as i say if we've made priorities
on
okay we cut here but that's the one we
at least wanted to cut so
that's that's where we'll put the money
first so that's that's the kind of thing
why we want to keep track thank you
so so could we go back to
the uh ways and means chair and and say
um on the 24th of of march
we're trying to be all done with the
division three
we would like you to give us your best
guess as of the 23rd
give us give us your your whatever
you're thinking on the 23rd
whether you're going to look at it again
in a week or two but just tell us what
you think on the 23rd
i'll have a conversation with him to
that effect
okay i mean all right
so that would it seems to me like that
would lay out a logical sequence i don't
know if ways and means
is could accommodate it but i i i hope
they could
i mean if nothing else they would say
you know whatever we voted in last
session is still their current estimate
you know but but if they're thinking
something different it'd be good to
to get an informal update i think there
might be some key report
and maybe the date of that key report
would trigger the whole thing so
i'll have that conversation thank you
sir
um okay so um
so i i i think i'm done saying
everything i wanted to say
is there or for the good of the division
does anyone have anything
they want to talk about that has not
been raised
and that and ms rounds that includes you
oh i do have one more thing for you ms
rounds
you know a couple of times
as we were going through the
department's increments and decrements
list
i made a comment that sounded something
like
you know i i understand your concept but
but we need something measurable to go
with this
so that we we know what we'd be getting
if we add or subtract and
uh and and in other words i was looking
for
more specific metrics associated with
the five percent
increment or decrement than what many of
the slides
were sharing okay do you know if
people are working on giving us better
metrics around the increment
and decrement list yes if it was on the
follow-up questions list which i believe
it was
that jonah provided me we we are working
on that i know at least chris
santaniello is for dehs
um so i'll make sure that
that if it's not on there for for katya
for behavioral health that we do
um add it on there jonah so that we make
sure we get it to you
and i'll mention it to the future
presenters as well
okay i know we've asked for a lot of
things but as we're as we're just kind
of
taking a look at the big picture here
that the details on the increment and
decrement list are really going to be
important
okay all right so um i'll try again
anything for the good of this vision
anyone
uh let's do one last opportunity for the
attendees to raise their hand
in case somebody's got something to make
us a smarter better
public servant so
i'll give you about 20 seconds to try to
figure out how to raise your hand
okay i'm not i'm not seeing any so
i don't think we need a motion to
adjourn uh but i'm uh i'm ready to
adjourn are there any vetoes anyone want
to keep going
all right all right uh well thank you mr
ripley you had one last thing
so you did plan on coming back at one
for the last of the presentations
oh yeah yeah yeah one o'clock yep so i
think you would recess until one o'clock
in that case
okay so this is a recess until one
o'clock
thank you for that sure
um the establishment of the 10-year plan
uh mental health plan so i like that
graphic and
someday it might be interesting to put
sort of your best estimate of population
numbers in each of the bubbles
so we have some another sense of
of how how big an issue we've got
that is a really good point we um talk
about numbers in our briefing book
um and so the we always have that issue
of how many do we actually serve through
the publicly funded
system and how do we capture or quantify
those who fall out of the department's
purview so to speak for
funding of services but at the very
least i think you can refer to the
briefing book
which does break down the numbers served
in
so you can see um and we've talked about
this previously
both with the new hampshire hospital
presentation
and um on monday about the
increases that we're seeing and the
people who are seeking
services so the good news is they're
engaged in
services and the bad news is we're
seeing a
increased demand so this number 15
763 or 33
those are spread out amongst those five
bubbles or is that in
one particular bubble
so that is not so let's just go back and
look
so those would be the ones who are more
likely to be
in the top three so the three to the
right
um so those are the ones we
use that data from the community mental
health centers
and so that is where the provision of
those types of services
uh happens so outpatient treatment um
not so much the step up and step down
but um the crisis
and inpatient services so um
so yeah you know community education as
always that's
we think of it as population education
population
health and that is as broad a category
so this goes breaks it down a little bit
you saw this on monday
for children's behavioral health it does
it by eligibility category
and again shows the same level of
increase in
each of those categories and i'm sorry
it's hard to read that slide
i'm realizing either that or i need to
put on my glasses
okay
that's a big number of serious
and um we're you know we're prepared to
go uh talk to you about what that means
there's a definition that's in
law and it's also commonly used
and part of the everyone's definition
federal definition of what severe mental
illness is and what
so this really talks about what the
responsibility of the bureau
is in overseeing the provision of these
services
i would be remiss if i didn't recognize
that i'm not
sitting here just representing the
bureau but i'm also also representing
the dozens and dozens
of community service providers who are
actively working um today um
to address the needs as well as the
thousands of individuals who need our
services
and so we break it down you'll see
community mental health centers
as we talked about on monday
there are 10 centers situated
in geographic locations throughout the
state
you all have them in your districts
and hopefully you know them and if you
don't it would be great for you to
connect with them or
them to connect with you to talk more in
more detail about the types of services
that they provide
so they have the outpatient services
emergency
services we have the mobile crisis
response teams we talked about monday
and those
are for adults and they include four
respite beds in each of those three
regions which include
concord manchester and nashua
and that is the program that we want to
integrate
and expand and have all populations
served
and have it be a statewide system
so are all the mobile uh systems
so hmm that's a good question i think i
will have to ask
jane to answer that because i think we
have the mobile crisis
that are currently in existence are in
our
current budget and carry forth
but then dollars were added um
to expand and i believe that we had
dollars
put into both the bureau of children's
behavioral health
and this particular bureau and jane
could you just validate that
yes yep you're correct there is money in
4117 our accounting unit here in mental
health
and there's also money in 2053
in the children's behavioral health
i'm sorry you didn't hear me uh i you
started i heard i i heard you up until
you said the first half and then i
couldn't hear you after that
okay so there's money in the accounting
unit
4117 which resides in mental health
which is where we're at and there's also
money in 2053 which was talked about
on monday in the children's behavioral
health section okay so are these mobile
crisis
i'm sorry uh i thought you were done
that's okay go ahead
so are these mobile crisis teams are
they
uh significantly different from one
another to where one has
a more of a pediatric bent to it and one
has a more adult bent to it
or are they sort of uh
like swiss army knives and can handle
any psychiatric crisis
so thank you that's a great question
because going forward we're going to
have it
be all encompassing um and that's what
we're working to put in place right now
statewide right now these three
particular teams
are comprised as
laid out in our community mental health
agreement the amanda d
settlement which we
work with closely with the plaintiffs on
overseeing
and maintaining a component of that
really dictates and it was agreed upon
what those tunes would look like and
who from a certification
and professional standpoint serves on
those teams
including peer peers who serve on those
each of the three areas have taken
somewhat of a slight slightly different
approach
um however they stay within that main
framework
in the agree that's called for in the
agreement so while
manchester may um be able to respond to
children
the other two are unlikely to do that
only because we fund them to support the
adult uh population and
agreement
the specialty services there's
residential services
reap when i saw that i'm like oh no
there's an
acronym we didn't spell out so that's
referral
education assistance and
prevention and that really serves the
adult population
um and if anybody well you couldn't have
been but on this morning
on the exchange they talked about this
program
specifically it's for individuals who
are in congregate care as well
as in the community and it is um
for adults 60 plus
so we have deaf and hard of hearing
services
and first episode psychosis
and that fep is how we refer to that
that really is trying to
provide that early intervention when
someone
first experiences a mental health crisis
and then the last one is a grant that a
federal grant that we have
pro-health integrated health care for
youth um specifically targeting that
particular age group which we talked
about again
on monday and that is looking at
integrating
physical health and mental health
services together
so there are many mental health centers
that have partnered with their federally
qualified health centers to really
provide
the what we all would like to see is the
integration and not have
separate um services or separate
approaches
for mental health and for physical
health
there's a question there with the
representative nordron thank you very
much
um i'm particularly concerned about the
north country
um could you address any
um programs or new availability of
services
up in the north country obviously the
three units are really
right where our population is but i
think the north country isolation
i think is a big concern to a lot of
people
thanks so you're going right to the
heart where my heart always is which is
the north country
i have an affinity for that area knowing
the challenges there however we do have
a statewide system
so the community mental health center
there has the same
level of services as the rest of the
state
the mobile response teams specifically
were targeted
because of the volumes and the
utilization as determined
through that period when we were
settling that court
case and so it was negotiated and
determined
that those three areas were in the
highest
need from a numbers count
we have worked really closely with eric
johnson
from northern human services
to look at his population
differently due to geography so while we
have
assertive community treatment teams
so those are called act services and
those are high intense
services for individuals um needed
at that level on ongoing um
he we have worked with him so that he
has uh
more than one team so while the other
centers
for the most part have one team although
manchester is the exception to that
um we've worked with northern human
services
to make sure that they had geographic
coverage so that nobody
is stuck um in littleton um
needing to seek services in conway for
example
but it is something that we monitor very
closely
and we know that um
that is an area that we need to continue
so the middle one about housing services
i think everyone
is acutely aware of the housing crisis
that we have
in the state of new hampshire as
evidenced by
the individuals who are homeless and by
just the tight
uh real estate market that we're reading
about every single day
so these housing services are specific
for
individuals with severe mental illness
that are in need of more support than
so transitional housing they need more
support than
just having a place to
stay so to speak so we have specialty
residential transitional housing many
people are aware that we have
transitional housing run by
nfi we're bringing up that acronym again
here in concord on pleasant street
where the state offices are we have
other
beds that are in housing programs that
are available
in a couple other parts of the state and
we're standing continuing to stand up
additional programs
the housing bridge subsidy program is
more
a traditional um approach where
we're able to provide a so-called
voucher
to an individual who qualifies
and this bridge in the whole point of a
bridge
is that it is someone who's eligible for
section 8
housing however they are going to be
waiting and waiting and waiting to
receive that section 8 housing
subsidy so we bridge that time between
when they are in need of housing and
when they're going to be able to secure
that federal section aid housing so
um there are currently
we are in contract for 500
apartments for leasing up
we have many of those individuals come
from
new hampshire hospital and so when
heather marquin was speaking
about needing to find the so-called back
door and needing to work on that i think
she a couple times referenced to bridge
the bridge program well that's this
program and with that program
with the community mental health centers
and by our bureau
and the there is a sliding fee scale so
we only pay i think it's 689
a month um and there you know that's not
going to go very far in the seacoast
probably
um or anywhere right now so we do have
the ability to waive that
um if someone has an income then we
what question um help me put
500 apartments in context because i know
we have
a very high occupancy rate in
apartments so it feels to me like
500 statewide is
a really significant percentage of our
vacancies so
this program goes back a dozen years or
more and
um it has been very successful in the
way that it's been administered
in the development of relationships
it's always been 500 no
it just increased by 75 slots due to the
funding in the last um budget um
in the last biennium we were just able
to go to contract to increase
by 75. we are
that's all right i i thought it was a
bigger issue i thought you were
going to take 500 more new
units so you're just taking 75 more
to get to five up to 500 yeah so
administrator i just want to rep
representative waller has a question
sure
so katya i don't know if this is a good
time or not
for you to talk for a little a minute
about the community mental health
agreement
um sort of what i mean i don't know i
don't
i need a refresher as to what all was in
there and i do know that the expert
reviewer reviews us on a regular basis
and i
wondered how how we were doing when i
looked last time
it seemed that way there were some areas
that we were still
um not not quite there yet so
could you when the appropriate time uh
if you could talk a little bit about
that
well on this slide um there are a lot of
things here that
um are the backbone of the
agreement and what we are standing up
for services and have stood up so the
housing bridge is a perfect example of
that
um it called for x number of slots to be
available
that we were to achieve that and we were
given a ramp-up period over
three or four years and so um i believe
that 500 number
now exceeds what was in the agreement
however the agreement also indicates
that we would seek additional funding
if a waitlist were developed and
right now the wait list is relatively
manageable
but we know with the way things are
going
and with new hampshire hospital having
trouble with that
back door that that that's an area that
we need to focus on
so the premise of the suit was that
new hampshire was um unnecessarily
um institutionalizing individuals with
severe mental illness
due to the lack of community services
and so
we were the lawsuit was filed by the u.s
department of justice
and the disability rights center and
um there's another organization that's
also involved
and so we were able to come to an
agreement
it was funded in a special session i
believe it was 2013.
um we started getting some funding for
this it was uh
off budget year so that was difficult
but we were able to do that
and the components of it is really
looking at community-based services
so who from new hampshire hospital
doesn't need to be there
if but for the community services if
they
if they have access to community
services the other
population that's addressed is the going
club home so you heard
uh todd bickford talk about glencliff
and um we
were obligated under the agreement and
were successful
in transitioning 16 individuals
out of ground club home into
community-based settings
and there are a lot of details about the
definitions
and i'd be happy to share the agreement
as well as the latest
expert reviewer report that was just
issued
in jean at the end of january and so
it has major categories of what we need
to provide in services
including housing including those three
mobile crisis teams
including a number to have the capacity
to serve 1500 individuals statewide
for the assertive community
treatment which i indicated before which
is that
intensive service typically someone who
is on an team needs ongoing
long-term support and intense
services and those are likely to be
individuals who are transitioning
from new hampshire hospital and
that capacity is one area that we
continuously
struggle with in not having um 1500
people
who have um we haven't achieved that
number
of serving 1500 we've been hovering
around the same amount
for several years and we've had
discussions about
whether there really is the need um to
build that much capacity or if other
types of services
would be um
appropriate to serve the same
individuals that would be
served by act but at a different um a
your hand is still up do you have
follow-ups
no i i want to say i want to thank katja
for that
and if it's possible i i think i know i
would like to
see the agreement again and i don't have
it
i'm right here on my desk so i'm sure
you do
so maybe other people would like to see
it too so you can sort of read through
it to see
what the uh the state's responsibilities
are
so i think that falls under our general
way of distrib
distributing documents mr ripple catches
them
and makes sure we all have them and if
appropriate it gets
how how long are we under this agreement
miss fox
until we achieve um the all the
components and come into compliance
and so it was originally envisioned to
be five years
it's now been um closing i think it's
been
six or seven years um i think it was
um i can't remember if it was 2013
yet was signed or february of 2014 and i
have to
pull it out from my pile um
we um have we've gone past the five
years
is the bottom line and we continue to
have that expert reviewer
monitor um for a number of things
including an expectation around quality
and we will only
not be under the agreement when we
achieve the goals
and come into compliance and then it's
monitored for one year
that we maintain that for one year
and so we're in it for
i don't see any more questions you can
drive on
okay peer recovery we talked about this
with
um the um individuals with a substance
use disorder
this is also a really big component of
the mental health system
we have eight agencies that have 14
locations that are in
each of the regions those 10 regions
around the state
again these are lean organizations that
have
some paid staff but many volunteers as
well
and they are trained and
they have office hours so they're
they're
in person drop-in centers and
they they're a key like i said a key
component
we have family peer support um as well
so that we can assist families as they
try to assist their
we have the inpatient so all of a sudden
we're skipping
we're going from one level to um
the acute level and so in addition to
new hampshire hospital new hampshire
hospital is designated
as a designated receiving facility
so those beds are known as drf beds
we have community-based drf beds
and those are located in manchester at
elliott hospital
and the cypress center which has um
that's under the
mental health center of manchester we
have
in nashua we have them franklin
derry and portsmouth and we're
frequently looking to expand that
and then the other is guardianship
services
if you recall in on monday one of my
early slides was
talking about the need for 10 additional
slots
and you questioned that it was only 30
as a prioritized need and that is indeed
the case
so that's that service and again those
are guardians that are appointed
um to help individuals
with basic life skills
and overseeing their finances and
okay so that's everything i remember
from the guardianship i don't think i
asked you how many clients can one
guardian
service so
now julian gets to be on camera if she
knows but
um i do know that we have contracts
with two um
agencies organizations that and one is
um
the office of the public guardian um but
julianne do you know the answer to that
question of how many they serve
i know um we can get that if if you
don't have it it's not urgent
yeah as you said it's under their
contract so we contract them for a
particular number of slots but i don't
have that information
right in front of me if we can follow up
with that
i'm just looking through my my notes to
see
i mean i'm just thinking aloud you know
that that's got to be
one of the most cost
effective i don't know if it's
clinically effective but
it it or the extent to which it's
clinically effective but that
sounds like one of the least expensive
ways that we can
help our clients so i do have a little
bit of information that i used um
to flip to the page so the per diem
payments for guardians
is 8.25 and
um in one contract and the other is six
dollars and
81 cents in our case loads
and this includes for individuals with
an intellectual disability as well
um our case loads for state fiscal year
20 were 1035
and we expect um in that to increase by
about
and i will say this is an area that we
often have to transfer
funds because we're obligated to provide
these services
and um so so we're always looking
gap
so this really just gives a coverage map
for the mental health region
so again probably can't see it
um but um you can blow it up on the um
on the screen with your individual um
documents that were uh shared with you
via email i believe
so we have 10 uh community mental health
programs up
that's what the map covers um we have a
community mental health provider
that's the aforementioned nfi we have
the eight
peer support agencies with 14 locations
around the state
we have the family mutual support agency
which
um is ken norton's
group tsunami new hampshire um we have
the suicide prevention line and i know
this was raised i believe by
representative norgren
on monday about the funding that went to
headrest
um so that was the first time in the
last
biennium that was funded state funds
going for the suicide prevention line
and so we have hundred thousand dollars
that's one contract
with headrests to provide that service
we have the designated receiving
facilities that we talked about
we have the legal services that we just
talked about
and then we have some technical
assistance training that's provided to
um all of our providers and in some
cases to the community
representative edwards i think we we
couldn't really hear you there
oh i i think i am having some internet
problems but
um uh i'm just curious on a time check
how much time do we need to adequately
address these slides
i i i i in the back of my head i think
somebody on the committee
said they needed to leave today at three
o'clock
and and and i don't know if i'm just
confusing that with
representative walner tomorrow or or
what but
but does does anyone have to leave
prior to three o'clock i
show a 2 30 uh meeting with with the lba
yeah i think i think there's a 2 30
meeting with mike kane that
you representative edwards and
representative weiler
okay so uh and then i have to present
testimony at two so so representative
earth if you'll
get get on deck to to take over cheering
uh but if if
if we could move through the slides just
a little bit faster you're doing great
and i'm asking you a lot of questions so
um i realize i'm part of the problem but
let's try to go yeah and um i can pretty
much guarantee that we can toggle this
any way that you'd like um and
certainly be finished in the next half
hour or so depending on
questions i could talk about this all
day every day
um so so if you need to
just start waving at me and tell me to
so the key accomplishments this is
looking
at the expansion of the system where we
got
um the opportunity to invest in
the 10-year plan so the 10-year plan was
established and then we received the
investments
and so we were able to do many of these
items that you see listed here as a
result of that
opportunity so we
added the drf beds to the system
again always looking to do that to
expand
those beds as you know today's wait list
unfortunately
hit that 60 number
that we were fearful of and so we want
to expand those services
and we're in the process of um
procuring for additional step up and
stuff down
uh beds we've added um beds for
the peers of the peer agencies are
running those respite beds
um and and so on so
we're we're looking at expansion there
um
we have the crisis response system
you've heard about that previously
about what our vision is with that with
that hub
serving as the central portal and then
working in the regions to have the
crisis response
this is really important because ken
norton from nami raised it and i just
want to put a little
emphasis on it 988 is the federally
designated phone number
for suicide prevention um and
as ken talked about we'd love to see
that encompass and be all encompassing
for
all on mental health services and be
able to
collapse those dozens and dozens of
numbers so that
individuals and families have access to
one number similar to what
we know for covid response right now is
two one one
so we were able to um
apply for and receive a grant
and it's a planning grant to get ready
for that 2022
rollout and we have funding that's
available to headrest
and so we'll be contracting with
headrest
to really do that due diligence with
planning
and that includes planning with the
department of safety
around 9-1-1 what happens when a number
comes into 988 and it should go to 9-1-1
or vice versa it's coordinating with
2-1-1
and other hotlines and
parties that would be interested in
making sure that
that we're really taking into
consideration
how people access services
so we also in the budget in addition to
that two hundred thousand dollars
there was funding set aside for suicide
prevention that was
um pretty wide open the suicide
prevention council
asked us to hire someone and establish a
position within the department
to be the suicide prevention coordinator
to work really closely
with the council in carrying out its
mission and
its strategic plan and that person
is going to start um in i think
next week or the week after um so we're
able to
establish that and then we've also been
doing a number of
trainings and working on
a statewide campaign to
really get that information out there
that there is help
um and that people don't have to
so again we were able to move the bridge
subsidy program
from one administrator to the community
level
so the community mental health centers
were very excited and we were excited
that they took on
the ability to work locally with their
landlords in their communities
to be able to help the individuals in
their region secure that housing
so this type of housing is not
you go to a big building um that is for
all individuals with severe mental
illness this is
really integration into the community
and finding
apartments and working with landlords
so that they understand the value
of being able to provide that type of
housing
and knowing that the committee mental
health center is providing that support
and then again a focus on peer
support and making sure that peers are
available
to individuals and not just having
and workforce workforce workforce we're
going to keep bringing it up
so um under key challenge oh i should
pause
i'm sorry oh there's uh representative
nordron
yes question i just
wanted to make a bit of trivia come in
um
headrest was started um in
1969 by students in the
basement of a dartmouth door so
it goes way back to that
genesis here on campus at dartmouth just
trivia
were you part of that sharon what were
you part of that dartmouth basement
group no no no
all right so key challenges and
a significant program that we've been
able to invest in
it was basically very underfunded and
doing a lot of work
and now is being able to grow to meet
the demand
so we're pleased about being able to
partner with them
so again back to the challenges
affordable housing we've talked about it
we know about it
the council on housing stability that
was established by the governor
and of which many housing providers
and community service providers
sit on is looking at this and looking at
specific populations including the
populations that our division
service the
workforce again um this was
discussed previously and we'll continue
to sorry can
can we go to the next slide i i i would
like to keep us moving and these
challenges are
are we we've talked about these before
and they're indeed
serious challenges sure
so now this is the um budget chart
and i believe karen um shines in here
and jane can as well if you have
questions sure
so the um the changes that i would
mention here
the the decrease in federal funds was
the end
of the uh disrip dish p waiver
um so that's what the reduction in
federal funds are there that we've ever
ended
12 31 of 2020
so the federal funds are less um the
increase in general funds that you're
seeing
are the 10-year mental health plan that
katya has been
i'm sure talking about yeah i think
we've
um have access to that 10-year mental
health plan
um already but if we could put a link
on the lba site miss ripple would
i i saw you say yes with your head so
what else about this slide ms rounds i
don't think i have anything else though
and i think that this is probably
something you want to skip over to
because you've seen this some of this
um uh about what we would be able to do
with
um five percent more and what would
happen if we
go five percent less i will point out
that we are
always concerned about making sure that
we have
the funding necessary to carry out the
requirements under the committee mental
health
agreement so
so like for example on the decrement
where you say a reduction would
necessarily
necessitate a reduction of non-medicaid
billable services
are you also implying from what you just
said that it could cause us to
be out of compliance with our agreement
it could um many of the components of
the agreement
require general funds so housing is not
something that we can um
bill medicaid for there are some
services that
can be but actual bricks and mortar and
um the leasing of that apartment
so to speak um is not something that
there's any other funding for
so you know my general comment on this
the more that this is understandable in
terms of measurables
the the more useful it is to the
committee
so um
so i like for example the third bullet
down
on increments because you start to talk
about
actual staff numbers and what they do
but
if you could help us further by you know
what
what does improving compliance mean
that doesn't that doesn't say much uh
and
tangible i mean i mean i know what
you're getting at but you will see
that um as part of the 10-year plan
refresher that
um you're going to have the link to that
there is a huge
emphasis on that quality um so that's
the improving
um the quality piece but also the
compliance in that
um when we share with you the expert
reviewers report
you'll see where we are out of
compliance
very good
are you doing with vacancy rates we like
to know about those too
yes we currently i believe um
we have four positions that are vacant
right now
um we are very fortunate that we have
been given the green light to go ahead
and fill positions
and so some of them have already
throughout the division have been posted
um and will be posted within the coming
weeks
um and again that just takes the you
know that time so we had this period of
time where we didn't
have enough staff to take on all of the
challenges
um but it will be a ramp up time for
those staff to get up to
uh speed unless we do what unfortunately
has been happening a lot lately people
are moving within the department
um so then there's always a vacancy um
left behind when someone moves into
another position
so it's a great opportunity for our
workforce because they're able to
see a career path does create challenges
when we have those
and then i think you'll like these
benchmarks
maybe they resonate a little bit more
than
um the previous ones that we shared on
monday
we're actually working on providing you
a more comprehensive response at your
request
yeah i like the quality metrics it looks
like that's where
the best work is you know for example
the processing housing applications
that's a workload measure
you know i i is there some standard
of how many applications you want to
fulfill in a given month or something
that's that's where that's going
and this slide is a long-term project
where we can communicate to each other
over the long run this isn't fix it now
this is
you know we're having a conversation
about future conversations
and then again turning it over to karen
audrey if you want to stop sharing i
will go ahead and share my screen
if i had if i could do this one more
time during
the house phase then i would actually
remember that
all right so the first accounting unit
we're going to start with
is the pro health new hampshire grant
which is on page
11 22. so
this is a good place for me i think to
um
turn it over to representative irf as uh
as
our vice chair to go ahead and share the
rest of this
i'll come back uh after i've given my
okay are you ready i don't i don't
mean to just dump it on you but i was
i like it all right um thank you
so much um miss fox and i'm sorry i'm
missing your presentation miss jackson
but it's going to be on video so i'll
have some late night viewing
so for the pro health grant 2340 is the
accounting unit starts at the bottom of
this is one where we've moved the
contracts from 102 to 74 for that
okay all right
is accounting unit 4113 which is
consumer and family affairs
that starts at the page of 11 23 and
goes on to 11
24. is this how hot just said the mobile
units
were i don't believe
where it is just remind me that where
they are so i can put them in the right
place
you don't look it up right now just when
you get there we will get to it yep
okay the next accounting unit is
accounting unit 4114 which is
guardianship services
if you remember correctly there was a
small prioritized need here for about 30
um i believe only in fiscal year 23.
so a question here that it looks
yes we we had to increase the contract
quite a bit uh
i'm going to say it was like early
summer late spring
and i think katya can speak to why um we
so i'm i'm going to defer to jane if
needed
but we did have to increase it because
the rates were increased
by the court system so they set the
rates and also
um as you heard from some of those
numbers i gave you it's a pretty low
amount
but that again we're always running
short
and we don't want to run short in this
particular area because
as jane knows we're always trying to
find um
other funds within the division to
transfer to this so we wanted to fully
fund it this time around
thank you everybody
[Music]
the next account county unit is 4115
and this you'll see that there's an
increase in line 550 but you can see
that our
actual expenses for 2020 are far in
this is another area um karen and
and the group that we are often trying
to find money to transfer
because we don't really have a lot of
control over how the expenses come in to
us
and this is um the legal services these
are the individuals um the
attorneys who represent individuals who
are under
an involuntary status and their
appointed counsel so we have attorneys
any other questions appears not go ahead
karen the next accounting unit is 4116
which is
interim care funds it's at the top of
because we are level funding with fiscal
year 20
with what is budgeted i believe this is
i mean it's a fairly small amount but
it's one of those things we never know
for sure what the utilization is going
to be so we just
level fund and obviously lapse or
sometimes transfer to those other lines
short
i think we're good the next accounting
unit is 4117 which is
cmh or community mental health program
support
uh this if i am correct
is where those additional uh
units are teams are yes thank you as
well as the
most of the 10-year mental health plan
is within this accounting unit
i believe i'm sorry go ahead i was going
to say i believe the appropriation for
fiscal year 20 was closer to fiscal year
21.
um jane correct me if i'm wrong but i
think the appropriation was a little
closer to the
to the 28 million and this is one of
those areas that there were new funding
there was new funding and
covid uh and the contracting delayed our
ability to
contract those funds they see jane not
on your head so okay yes
right so those funds didn't lap so they
carried over into 21.
that's true you mean that's why the 21
number is
so much bigger than that now that
that number wouldn't reflect the carry
forward that was the level that
20 was funded at as well
or fairly close to that
right
so the 2020 column that you're looking
at is actual expenses
and the 2021 is an uh adjusted
authorized
budget so what karen was saying was the
20 20
actual expenses are a little bit well
quite a bit lower
because that was when we were trying to
get the programs ramped up
the budget for 2020 was actually closer
to the 27 million dollar number
but weren't able to spend all of the
funds and they
um carried forward this accounting unit
um
and that line item has a
budget footnote that allows us to carry
the funds forward within the biennium
this 28 million does not reflect any
carry forward
do you happen to rec recall that 20
uh i don't but it was it would would
have been
quite a bit lower because the 10-year
mental health plan
was um funded substantially in the 2021
budget
okay that's what i thought so i'm just
wondering given that there's still a
pretty good bump
going into the next biennium as well is
that
we explain how that was accounted for
and i just didn't hear it
um so it looks like it's about uh 100
yeah i'm not sure exactly what the
increase is there
so we can provide that level of detail
it's to carry on the
services that are being put into place
today
that's the other hand stigmas will
the next accounting unit is 4118 which
is
and that is a pretty good jump in
is that
it looks like uh jane and peer support
that were no longer budgeting the
federal funds was this dish
dish p yes so this these federal funds
were related to the waiver that ended
um on twelve thirty one twenty so
that's what that's why that got added
into general funds yes what i would
share with you and it
it's a little confusing to understand so
we could have a separate conversation
if you want to um but these expenditures
were happening prior to that waiver
and when that waiver was put in place
these
um these expenditures then got a federal
match
and the general funds that were budgeted
here were then moved
to essentially support the idn project
so the net impact of the department for
the idn
project was essentially zero
so now that that waiver has ended and we
no longer have contracts with the idn's
those general funds are essentially
moved back to here so
across the budget it's in that zero but
it shows as an
increase here when we get to the
medicaid division and you see that the
idn account is no longer budgeted you'll
see
several million dollars of general funds
there that are not
being brought forward thank you i was
actually i've already seen the id and
account and i was wondering where all
those funds went
so there's most of them are still in
that same account just moved over to
general funds
the the i the funds that you would have
seen in that idn
accounting unit that are no longer there
have moved back across the department
most of them are
in behavioral health but there's a small
amount that was in public health
uh were there any long-term supports and
services
jane no i don't think so i think it was
mostly behavioral health
and they would be going to general funds
in those other accounts is that what
you're
yes yes so those general funds that were
in the id and account are now sort of
back across the department okay is it
possible for you to um
generally list of where those all went
yes without too much trouble
yeah i'm pretty i don't know if we have
it easily in a spreadsheet but
um we can give you a general idea the
earnings change year to year but
we can give you a general idea of where
they are okay it's a problem to worry
about i was just i have to notice that
ibm thing is that
we were so involved with that last time
yes i wonder what happened to
a lot of money there yep they're back
across the department
anybody else the next accounting unit is
there's not much of a change here just
level funding
so 4120 is the mental health block grant
so this is um where i noted that the um
one for substance abuse from the federal
government is
about 7.2 million and then the one for
mental health services is considerably
less than that
um we did receive in the federal budget
um
a five percent increase with it targeted
and specified for emergency response
so that will be coming forward if it
hasn't already in this budget
we'll need to bring it in throughout
these
the legislative process
okay and
the question on the first on the
previous page
yes at two million dollars under grants
for public assistance and relief
that was that's something new put in
there what what does that money go for
that's actually being moved from class
line 102. that's the
um change that i've talked about where
we're moving
where we're budgeting those to better
account for the single
audit so that it was previously on 102
that's now down to 170 000
and now they're they're on class line
74.
and the last accounting unit is 4121
what agency is that i'm always curious
about where these agency funds come from
oh give me one minute sorry
don't worry about it i thought you might
not top your head okay
i'm just always curious when i see these
how these funds flow around where they
flow from into
oh that's actually from um eagle
technologies
well that's right this
katy do you want to take the first stab
at explaining that one no it's okay you
don't need it
it's a little confusing it took me some
time to understand exactly
it is federal funding that comes through
a third-party source is the way i would
just
yes that's that's a nice simple way
thank you
so that um concludes
the accounting units for behavioral
health
is there anything else we were scheduled
to do this today
to bail out and have jess come back a
day late moment later and say where are
you
so um thank you mr chair
and members of the committee
we are as i said indicated earlier we
are working to provide the information
that's already been requested
then we'll work through karen to get
that to you and
we'll add the additional requests um
made today
awesome thank you very much katya and
karen and
julianne is that right
is that it guys or what what kevin what
come off mew yep i think that's it you
don't have anything else scheduled for
today so you can uh
join the meeting meeting if you'd like
representatives anybody else have any
questions or thoughts or anything there
no
all silent even ken silent okay i guess
we'll adjourn then
thank you all 10 30 and friday okay